hey there everybody i
am
what you call evil saddler i like to
think of it as being
bad sadler i don't know why the negative
has to be construed as evil
bad is bad enough and
this is the first of who knows how many
of these videos where i'll get to
say my piece out to you and maybe
counteract some of the work that greg
sadler's been doing you can call me gerd
so that we can distinguish me from from
greg
and the first thing i want to talk about
today
is all of this emphasis on reading
primary texts when it comes to
philosophy
you don't need to do that as a matter of
fact just you know reading wikipedia
articles that's probably
good enough if you really really need to
have a book in your hands
why not just stick with this bertrand
brussels the history of western
philosophy a lot of people think that
it's really great and you can think that
it's really great too you can read what
russell has to say
and
parrot it and that's really all we do in
philosophy anyway doesn't it just
talk a lot we don't get anywhere
i've got a whole stack of books here
that i think you don't need to actually
read let's let's talk about them john
locke an essay concerning human
understanding
look at how thick this book is do you
think he understands anything
if it was a good book it would be nice
and short as a matter of fact let's take
a a nice short look in here we don't
have too many of them but this is
shorter
aristotle's nick of mccann ethics what
kind of a loser rights and ethics to his
his son i mean if he was a good dad
his son would be ethical already
wouldn't he
and you know
this this copy is actually just full of
all sorts of notes and things like that
you don't need all that garbage
being in time
you're already being you're already in
time you don't need this garbage
to you know read your way through and
find out about
equipmordials and logos and
phenomenology and being towards death
you're going to find out death soon
enough sooner or later
kicker guards philosophical fragments
why do you have to write a whole book of
fragments and it's a disappointment
because these aren't fragments they're
long long chapters with all of this
verbiage about god and socrates and
diogenes and the eternal
he doesn't even write under his own name
he's some other guy
epicurus's discourses he didn't write
down his own stuff this is from aaron
how do you know any of this is real and
not just all
made up
maybe
stoicism is very different than what
epictetus or aryan is telling you
don't rely on this
and some of canterbury the major works i
mean who reads this crap you know the
monologian pro slogan why god became man
the various theological treatises i mean
if people were reading this a lot they
could be major works but
not that many people
go through these things anymore
uh here's another obscure one lucretius
on the nature of the universe a nice
poem
but there's no poetry in it it's all
prose
why read this
you know can we just summarize up the
epicureans with eat drink be merry
because tomorrow you're going to die
why would you have to know anything
about the universe
and then you know
another one from ancient stuff seneca
the letters on ethics also known as the
moral letters or the letters to
machilius
these are long letters would you want to
get letters like this from somebody
preaching stoicism to you telling you
all this stuff that you don't really
need to know
probably not
boring stuff and finally we come to the
biggest offender of all
hagel's phenomenology of spirit
can't you just read some nice summary of
this secondary works are there
to be the bridge for you to help you
understand all of these things and look
at all the websites that are available
to you to give you summaries spark notes
you know uh the various encyclopedias
there's no need anymore for anybody to
read plato or aristotle or epictetus or
seneca all the way down to contemporary
stuff you've got other people to do the
thinking for you
why bother
that's my message for you today
maybe this will help to corrode and
counteract some of the work that the
other guy
the one who's in you know not negative
but
calls himself good greg
maybe this will
tear down some of that work and pull the
wool that's been over your eyes away
from your eyes drop the scales whatever
metaphor you
like
give it a shot
read a secondary work today
put aside all of your
books that
have to do with original you know
thinkers and texts go out and get
yourself some nice summaries and then
sit around the coffee house or the bar
wherever you like to be
and spout your stuff
you